[تصفيق]
خلال فترة حكمها ، احتفلت الملكة إليزابيث
بثلاثة يوبيلات تاريخية
في عام 1977 يوبيل سيلفا
الذهبي في عام
2002 ويوبيلها الماسي في عام 2012.
هذا العام بعد أن تجاوزت بالفعل
فترة الحكم القياسي للملكة فيكتوريا
إليزابيث ، أصبحت أول ملكة بريطانية
تحيي اليوبيل البلاتيني
إنها سبعة عقود غير مسبوقة من
الخدمة
خلال فترة حكمها التاريخي ، فقد
عينت 14 رئيسًا للوزراء والتقت بـ
12 رئيسًا أمريكيًا ، وقد تشرفت
بمشاهدة بعض ذلك التاريخ ، لقد
كانت منارة للاستمرارية خلال
فترة غير مسبوقة من التغيير ، ليس أقلها
ثورة وسائل الإعلام
أعظمها.  ربما
كان الإنجاز هو قدرتها على أن تظل ذات صلة
وشعبية مع
اقتراب عيد ميلادها السادس والتسعين بالنسبة
لكل شخص يعيش تقريبًا ، فهي الملكة البريطانية الوحيدة التي عرفوها على
الإطلاق
مع عدم وجود خطط للتقاعد ، وستقام سلسلة من
الاحتفالات على
مدار العام وستبلغ ذروتها في أربعة -  يوم
عطلة رسمية عطلة نهاية الأسبوع في يونيو
عندما يمكن للجمهور الانضمام إلى موضوع اليوبيل
تتوقع الاحتفالات أبهة رائجة وحفلات شوارع احتفالية وعروض استعراضية
مع بعض من أكبر النجوم في العالم
المقرر حضورها ،
وستكون هناك بعض المفاجآت في
جعبتهم حقًا يدرك القصر
تمامًا مثل الجميع حيث كان هذا
وقتًا طويلاً.  لقد كان المرء
قادرًا حقًا على الاحتفال لفترة طويلة جدًا ، لذا
نأمل أن يكون هناك حفلة كبيرة
سيكون كوبي خلفنا ويمكن للناس
الاحتفال في الهواء الطلق وفي الداخل
بالطريقة التي يحبونها
[تصفيق]
بعد واحدة من أكثر السنوات صاخبة
في العصر الملكي الحديث  تأمل الملكة
في إعادة التركيز على
مستقبل النظام
الملكي ، حيث غمرت الأسرة
سلسلة من الخلافات والفضائح ،
لكن لا يزال يبدو أن المؤسسة تظهر
قوتها من خلال
رأسها الصوري
الذي لا يتزعزع والموقر بشكل كبير علينا أن نتذكر
ذلك  عندما اعتلت العرش في عام 1952
، لم يكن ذلك حقًا وقتًا مستنيرًا للغاية
فيما يتعلق بالمرأة العاملة ، حيث اعتقد الكثير من
الناس أن المرأة  لم تكن على
مستوى الوظيفة على الرغم من حقيقة أن الملكة
فيكتوريا وجميع الملكات من قبل
كانوا ملكات عظماء على العرش ، فقد
أثبتت أنهم جميعًا مخطئون
وأثبتت مرارًا وتكرارًا أن المرأة
يمكنها القيام بعمل
الملك الدستوري  تمامًا كما لو لم يكن أفضل
من رجل
لأول مرة هذا العام ،
ستكون إليزابيث بدون الأمير فيليب في احتفال ملكي كبير ،
سيتدخل
الرجل الذي كان بجانبها شخصيًا
ومهنياً طوال فترة حكمها
الأمير تشارلز للعب
دور رئيسي
كما ستكون كاميلا ويليام وكيت
هما المستقبل وسوف يكونان في المقدمة
والوسط جنبًا إلى جنب مع الملكة ،
وربما نتطلع أيضًا
إلى اليوبيل التالي عندما
تتفوق الملكة على لويس الرابع عشر في فرنسا
لتصبح أطول فترة حكم في
تاريخ العالم
كحد أقصى  فوستر CNN